well it seems
really difficult to build the detector
of intelligent
or intelligent conv communication
sort of uh if we take an alien
perspective observing earth
are you sure that they would be able to
detect humans as the special thing
wouldn't they be already curious about
other things there's way more
insects by body mass i think than humans
by far
and colonies obviously dolphins is the
most intelligent
uh creature on earth we all know this so
it could be the dolphins that they
detect
it could be the rockets that we seem to
be launching that could be the
intelligent creature they detect
uh it could be some other uh trees
trees have been here a long time i just
learned that sharks have been here
400 million years and that's longer than
trees have been here
so maybe it's the sharks they go by age
like there's a persistent thing
like if you survive long enough
especially through the mass extinctions
that could be the
the thing your detector is uh detecting
humans have been here for a short time
and we're just creating a lot of
pollution but so is the other creatures
i don't know you do you think you would
be able to detect humans like how would
you go about detecting
in that computational sense maybe we can
leave humans behind
in the computational sense detect
interesting things
uh do you basically have to have a
strict objective function by which you
measure
the performance of a system or can you
find curiosities
and interesting things yeah well i think
that the first
measurement would be to detect how much
of an effect you can have in your
environment so if you look at
look around we have cities and that is
constructed environments and that's
where a lot of people live most people
live
so that would be a good sign of
intelligence that you
uh don't just live in an environment but
you construct it to your liking
yeah and that's something pretty unique
i mean certainly
birds build nest and but they don't
build quite cities termites build
mounds and ice and things like that but
the complexity of the human
uh construction cities i think would
stand out even to an external observer
of course that's what
a human would say yeah and you know you
can certainly say that
sharks are really smart because they've
been around so long and they haven't
destroyed the environment
which humans are about to do which is
not a very smart thing
but we'll get over it i believe uh
and and we can get over it by doing some
construction that actually is benign
and maybe even enhances the
resilience of nature
you